so large incoming will you go to prom
with me
Gray's are doing this awesome event a to
all the boys I've loved before table
read slash this amazing event featuring
really important speakers and it's all
going to raise money for the black lives
matter movement to fight racial
inequality how did you come up with the
idea for this you know like a lot of
people we're just asking ourselves like
how can we do our part help because
we're coming from a place of at least
for me I felt like I was coming from a
place of ignorance and and a lot of it
was just what can I do to help and Lana
and I have always been I think bonded by
the fact that yeah we're actors but we
also like Lana has a charity as well
that she represents and I think I think
it kind of just came about is this
conversation we were having and why not
try I think to what Noah just said is I
have a scholarship with the Asia
Foundation that puts Vietnamese girls
through four years of high school
education and while we were actually
while we were shooting to all the sequel
for tava boys and doing press Noah and I
have always been close but we've really
bonded over like whoa I'm doing this
thing for my girls that I love and Noah
is doing this amazing thing favorite
names and and it's a passion that we
both both have so you're given the
incentives a tease of the third movie
how did you get approval for this so
this have to go up the ranks at Netflix
what happened Netflix has been so
supportive yeah this campaign and other
campaigns like it they've been
supportive of Elah movement they they
are incredible partners oh stop stop I
am NOT the only guy that got a letter
wow you really think that you're special
and they find out that she wrote love
letters to two guys well then what can
you tell me what can you tease about the
third movie
for the fans nothing no Lana I can tell
you I can tell you we shot it in
Vancouver in New York and Korea and we
shot the first one and two only in
Vancouver so our movie is a much bigger
because we shot in more places and now
I'm gonna shut up because okay
my last question let me ask you guys how
did you react shoot the third movie when
you found out what was happening in it I
loved it I loved it because one female
empowerment period that's how I reacted
you loved the famous Sex in the City
quote the most important relationship
you have is the one you have with
yourself
sure do that one before but oh my god
was that Sex in the City
yeah I've never watched sexy I can't
believe it that's the time in the
quarantine you know I should watch this
series or you think I should watch the
movie the series you know so the fans
are gonna get this do we have any idea
when the movie will come out absolutely
lutely not we're not telling you okay no
I don't know
I don't know I don't know wait here's
what I will say is look it's quarantine
Howard's very much shut down not a lot
can be produced what is amazing is that
you guys had already banked this movie
and done it so is there part of you that
just wants to give it to the fans Oh
Mike yo I
I was like let's just release it like
I've been just like watching and reading
so many people like my friends say oh my
god I've watched everything on Netflix
and I'm like now would be optimal
we're months into quarantine now how are
you both doing and the franchise aside
do you know what's next for you both
career-wise Lana I saw you just got moon
shot but again things are kind of look
see he's always cheerleading but yet
Lana I'll go to you first just how are
you doing quarantine is it spending time
with the fam and and what's next for
your projects given that things are kind
of uncertain right now yeah um
thank you for asking I feel like people
don't really ask how are you doing um
you know I'm doing I'm doing I think I'm
doing well I I I'll be honest I you know
there was a solid chunk of time during
quarantine as I'm sure everyone can
relate where it wasn't the easiest thing
just emotionally because it's like
having your life completely a like kind
of stopped but I am very excited because
you know I know that staying home and
and doing social distance and wearing my
masks like I know that that's actually
making actually making a change and like
there's real actual things that are you
know positive so I feel really good
because I know that I'm doing something
good for the planet but you know I I
think in terms of that I've been you
know just doing probably as much as
everyone else is doing and and and I've
also been you know having this moment to
really be able to educate myself and
like I can show you I don't know if
you'll be able to see but I can show you
like I have a list of books that I'm so
like stoked about cuz I never get to
read these books stack ever yes I have a
stack and I never get to read them but I
have the stack of books where I'm able
to educate myself and have the time to
do so which is really awesome for me so
I you know I'm doing it I'm doing you
know just
your average fine no good some makes
great some days are hot whatever
when covert 19 hit I data collected like
I just tried to figure out what was
going on and tried to share that data
was crazy cuz favorite Nations was
actually gonna drop our clothing line
unrelated to covert 19 we selected
different charities that are in
different industries whether it's clean
water human displacement social
injustice on and on and then coded hit
and it's like literally four days or
five days before we were gonna launch
and we pivoted and shifted into really
direct initiatives that were tackling
different parts of code in nineteen to
educate our collection are collected and
I think that was honestly what this made
me feel totally okay staying at home you
know I filled my day everyday you know I
woke up I gathered information I worked
on favorite Nations we've made it so
that we're literally not just get like
if you buy a hoodie I just want to
reiterate it because it's something
that's very special when you buy
something from favored nations like a
hoodie or a shirt a hundred percent of
the money that you give goes to charity
not a percentage not not all of the
profit not you know all literally all of
the money will go to the charity that
you get to select and so I me personally
I feel really great I feel like I'm not
doing enough ever in this time but it's
more so motivation than anything else
and and yet so I personally feel good
but I feel like I could be doing more
and it's because of people like Lana and
my team at favored nations that I feel
like I'm doing something so I'm grateful
to a lot of I'm grateful today
[Music]
you